so all he wanted us to do was to force
um feed him the chocolate give him
champagne and call him daddy my friend
was behind him and I was on the floor
like making him lick my um my hael my
stripper hael and she was she wanted to
love so much and I had to like put on a
poker face like I was this seductive
Fame but inside I really wanted just to
laugh hello everyone I am M and I am a
stripper and content creator and today
I'm going to be serving the honesty box
for lad
Bible let's
go okay so first question who is a
typical client is it just um businessman
you literally have everyone coming in
you have the average Joe you've got the
single guys you've got the young Lads
Just Want to Have Fun during the
weekends you've got obviously uh loads
of stagos um you've got the old man that
feels really lonely that he's wife
passed away and now he just want some
companies you have everyone and anyone
but yeah you do have loads of
businessmen especially if they travel
they own business they Bard in their
hotel room what do they do they come to
a strip club how much do you earn per
hour per dance per day per night shift
it can go from
minus1 as an example if you work in a
club that got really high house fees
during the weekend you have to pay your
entry to the club so that can go from
to like1 so if you don't make any money
you on minus the most I've made I guess
could be 1,500 2,000 night um if I have
to answer per Dance One Dance goes from
20 to 30 and an hour goes
from2 200 to 800 EOS that was the
maximum I did in can that was 800 per
hour do you feel that men respect you so
if we are talking obviously at a strip
club um it really depends some men I
would say that come to the strip clubs
it's like they've got this hate for
women because they are being rejected
outside the clubs but most men yes when
they come to the club it's like they
become little boys again you would have
those CEOs Finance guy businessmen
coming you would see them during their
meeting and then you're like hello how
are you and they're like they can't even
speak anymore literally they they lose
their words they froze you know so so
they do yeah once you speak to them and
you explain your story and why you're
doing the job or they do I think
businessmen actually really do respect
us because we sort of businesswoman as
well you know all my clients usually
they say like you should get into sales
you should get into sales like you're a
really good saleswoman you're a really
good sales person what's your favorite
song to strip to that on that make you
go off you have your typical 50 cents is
such a good one you know the one from
like the 2000 like in the club
candy shop oh my god when this comes on
all together like it's so good 50 cents
is really good you have cardi obviously
cardi is a classic and I think my
favorite stage song is britness Pier
Gimme More you know the first notes when
it comes on it's just very powerful so
yeah those are my favorite songs
definitely who is your weirdest client
so I was in can once um during the
summer and it was this um submissive guy
so we do have submissive people that
coming to the STP Club not sure why they
turn to the STP Club instead of going to
a dominatrix but it was sort of like
submissive and all he wanted us to do
with my friend was to um he had his
pocket full of chocolate bars like Lion
sneakers bounty we can think of he was
ordering the most expensive
champagne and in France in can you're
allowed to smoke inside a club so all he
wanted us to do was to force um feed him
the chocolate give him champagne and and
smoke and and call him daddy
which so weird my friend he was sitting
on the sofa my friend was behind him and
I was on the floor like making him lick
my um my hael my stripper hael and she
was she wanted to love so much and I had
to like put on a poker face like I was
this seductive F but inside I really
wanted just to laugh so yeah that was
really a weird client oh God there's so
many had one guy once um he didn't want
me to dance he just wanted me to stand
feet apart and have my hands behind my
back and he was just I don't know he was
standing in front of me and started to
like dance like that in front of me and
I was like my legs start to hurt and he
was like that's the whole point and I
was like you freak like he just wanted
my legs to hurt so you just got some
like psychological people I'm like you
need to go to a therapist not to a STP
Club do you have an alter ego at work
yes I do so my name at work is
Franchesca and Franchesca is very
confident she doesn't care about
anything I can talk to anyone I don't
care to be naked on stage and myself in
my real life I am petrified to just go
on a date go on an interview and I'm
like oh no I don't want to talk to
people I like to stay with at home with
a cup of tea watching Disney and at work
I'm a completely different person I
think it's all the lighting the costume
you know it's like just this actress
playing a role so yeah definitely have
an alter ego I like her does stripping
get confused with sex work yes it does
big time and it's really something that
really really annoyed me and this is why
I created my Tik Tok to talk about the
industry to try to break the
misconception around it because you have
loads of men that come to the club and
like okay can you do extra what you do
in VIP like if I pay this much would you
do x y and Zed when no originally
stripping is dancing that's all we do
it's a bit more than burlesque we
entertain you we give you a dance and
this is it unfortunately you have clubs
that will allow extra to happen but
originally it's not meant to happen if
you expecting extra go to a bruffle it's
easier you know now you get access to
prostitute to escort to sugar babies
like so easily those days so you know
there are many website many things you
don't need to go to a strip club to get
a girl so it does get confused and I
know we are classified as sex workers
which I have a little problem with that
I know we are like adult entertainers
which is fine but to me we should not be
classified as sex workers because we are
just dancers at the end of the day so we
do not provide sex who is your oldest
and then youngest client uh the oldest
client I had I think maybe 60 something
like that and the youngest was like
18-year- old they are so fny the 18y
olds they they want to marry you they're
like oh my God I want you to be my
girlfriend how can I have a girlfriend
after like you dance for me you're just
the most beautiful thing ever so they're
really really sweet and the oldest can
be really sweet as well sometime they
can be a bit like jerky but usually most
people are really nice so yeah oldest i'
say 60 youngest 18 what is the biggest
stigma around your work uh Lords
actually that we are trash that we are
home that we just sleep around that we
have sex for money that we are Cooke
head
alcoholic um that it's not a job uh that
it's always gangster coming to the club
doing their business meeting so yeah
loads of stigma uh which are most of
them are wrong I personally do not drink
loads of my friend don't drink don't do
any drugs or anything like that at the
end of the day strippers are very normal
girls um we're just doing a job we just
trying to pay our bills like anyone else
oh yeah yeah and that's easy money no no
no come for one shift and let's see if
it's easy oh yeah that we are stupid oh
my God that we are stupid and we can't
do anything else well no some girls like
my friends they were studying they
didn't want to work at McDonald they
wanted to enjoy their life a bit more so
we're studying Finance or law or
recruitment or whatever now they've got
like amazing career but yeah once upon a
time they W stripping that's a really
really big misconception about it there
are just girls like me that it was my
fantasy and I've done it and I'm happy
that I've done it it's going to the
strip club cheating in my world yes it
is like I would not like my boyfriend to
go to a strip club I know some girls are
very open they're very chilled with it
but to me it's not even the dancing
naked part is the fact that you end up
chatting to the girl you create a little
connection and that's what that's what
can be a bit threatening for me and why
would you spend your money on another
woman when you can spend it on me like I
really don't understand that concept why
would you spend like thousands on a girl
when when yeah you've got a wife or a
girlfriend at home so if you're in a
relationship you should not go to the
strip club are strip clubs a safe space
I feel safer in strip clubs than normal
club like regular clubs or on the
streets to be fair I've been more
harassed in normal jobs than at a strip
club obviously at a strip club I'm being
paid to get naked but I've realized that
men are even more polite sometimes at
the strip club that in like normal life
I just they be like oh is that okay can
I put my hands here or do you mind to to
take this off so it's very safe there
are cameras everywhere there are
bouncers you know if someone is doing
something bad bad straight away um call
a manager called The Bouncer and the
person is being like kicked out straight
away have you ever felt attracted to a
client yeah of course I'm human so you
know when they're very nice to you they
don't have to be good-looking but when
they're very nice to you they're um
interested by your story they talk to
you and and they spend loads of money um
yeah they make you like them my
boyfriend is a former client so yes I
was attracted to him I hunted them to be
honest it was not him that was chasing
me I chased him so yeah of course we are
only human you know we are talking to
people we get um attached to people if
you've got a regular so you're talking
to them like often so they become like
your friends so yeah we are not robot
obviously we get attracted to people do
you think stripping is degrading to
woman no I don't I don't think it's
degrading at all you know it's a it's a
job no one think any other type of
dancers has being degrading or actresses
or any artists I don't see why we should
see it as degrading it's a performance
is an entertainment it's like you want
to be a nun be a none you want to be a
stay home stay at home you want to be a
stripper you want to be a porn Style
just just be you know I just want women
to be who they want to be let's say and
not be judged for it what qualities do
you need to be a successful strioer oh
my God you need loads of patience
because those men oh my God they get on
my nerves you need to have a really
bubbly personality because loads of
people think you just here to dance when
dancing is maybe i' say 60% of your job
because after that you need to be able
to talk to people you need to be a
salesperson be invested in the person
you are talking to so you need to be a
therapist and actually an Entertainer a
dancer so yeah it's really loads of
quality and have loads of patience
because people can also be very rude uh
very mean and you have to not take it
personally and think like whatever do
you hate men now yes I do I really
really do hate men I'm sorry guys it's
not that I hate men it's just that we
see them in a different light that what
they would show to the general public so
we can see a very um Che icky Dark Side
to them because you would have men
obviously that are married their wife or
girlfriend are pregnant and they would
still come to the club that was still
trying to get your number still trying
to have sex with you so you just think
like is there is anyone out there that's
got any morals that is not going to
cheat or to flirt uh so it just make you
lose hope in humanity if that makes
sense um because you're just thinking
it's not just the businessman it's the
average Jo as well it's just anyone you
all think oh because he's a businessman
he's traveling he's going to cheat no it
just can be anyone when you start to
sweet talk a man and you just like
stroke his ego he's just lose his sense
completely and you just forget why he's
go at home so it's very very hard you
know if you start to date someone or you
in a relationship and your boyfriend or
husband is like I'm going out and you're
like where are you going to end up you
know you always have this in the back of
your head like where is the night going
to take you so you never really trust
someone 100% once you have done um this
job or any job job in the adult industry
to be fair how has your perception of
gender Dynamics shift entering the
industry so I would say that obviously
see loads of discrimination and I feel
that men can do whatever they want and
they would not be judged and we would be
judged for example I'm a dancer and I
know that if I want to go and get a
mortgage or I want to change career I
would be judged because once upon a time
I used to be a dancer or I don't know
even the girls are only or whatever but
do men that watch porn and go to the STP
clubs are being judged are they being
Limited in their everyday life for like
yeah doing their life no they are not so
it just yeah it's it's very unfair and
like when you're in this job you realize
how there is still discrimination with
uh the female in the adult industry in
general and men can get away with
anything and it's like we can't so yes
they are not being judged and we are
being judged for doing the job but they
are the the consumer and a not being
judge do women ever go to the strip
clubs yes they do and I don't like them
sorry ladies but you are the worst
client ever actually my worst client was
a woman uh really rude the thing is that
some ladies are really nice they really
want to come they really enjoy the girls
which is fine but most girls they come
with their boyfriend or their husband or
their work colleague and it's like
they've been forced to come so they're
very uncomfortable they're not confident
enough to see like a room full of
beautiful naked woman so maybe they feel
a bit insecure but then it projected in
on us and you would have some woman
sitting right in front of the stage like
it's X Factor or something with like
Simon cows and everything you're on
stage and we can hear you you know and
like oh can you see she's got a bit of
silly light here oh she's got small tits
oh her nose is like this and I'm like
well you know now me cbell you're save
girl like seriously and it's like we're
always about like oh woman empowerment
woman this woman that was like we should
start within us if that makes sense so
very hypocritical IAL from women and
yeah if they come with their husband and
don't want to be there sometime you end
up into arguments in front of us so you
like sits out and then he's like in
front of you just like what do I do so
it can be very awkward um so I'm not a
fan of dancing for couples or ladies
because it's always it's just awkward to
me uh and Lords of girls Lord of
strippers think the same it's not we're
not really fans of ladies coming to the
strip club do you find intimacy and
relationships challeng ing yes when I
was dancing um I literally didn't have
any relationship I didn't have time for
a relationship I didn't want a
relationship um because you learn that
your your time is very precious and
obviously I am getting paid to spend
time with a man so if I go on a date I
know it's horrible what I'm saying but I
don't want to spend my time waste my
time with someone I'm going to get bored
of and not get paid for it if that makes
sense is not what I'm expecting in my in
my real life but for me if I choose to
go on a date with someone is because
that person is very very special and I'm
like oh I'm going to have a genuine
amazing good time do you ever feel
self-conscious physically or emotionally
yeah we all have our days I guess and
this job is very very draining mentally
you know like I said like nighttime uh
facing a sudden reality with men Etc and
like the way the world is and obviously
discrimination and all that that's what
loads of girls are taking long breaks is
never a job that you do for example for
five years without any breaks usually
the girls are taking like I'm not
working this month oh I need to take two
weeks off so it's it's not very
consistent some girls are very very good
you know but I think if maybe a bit more
like empathic and you feel like your
emotion a bit too much you have to take
breaks if not you can have a mental
breakdown because yeah mentally can be
very very draining what do you love
about your job you you know what I
really love just like getting ready
feeling glamorous uh feeling confident
feeling pretty and just go and meet my
girls stripping like the best part is
when you have a good time with your
friends with your coworker and you all
get along and then you get into a VIP
with your friend and the guys are
spending loads of money and it's just
like a giant party you're having fun
with your friend is like creating
amazing memories and you get paid on top
of that so I think yeah he just meeting
the same uh similar girls as me
obviously yeah I think I love the most
is like the connection with the girls
and obviously the dancing part and it's
just it's just fun all shapes and
sizes kinky ones long ones short
ones sh thick short ones thin tall ones
you know I think I don't know 6
in that I can get my fingers round